what's up what's it
you know we don't really be there if
Roman wasn't driving Fort Knox on Wheels
you you see me shining baby
we're locked inside it's a trap that's a
bomb all right dorks what are we blowing
up what the Vatican
we're going to hell
oh
the great Dom Toretto if you never would
have gotten behind that wheel
I'd never be the man I am today
and now I am the man who's going to
break your family
Peace by peace the devil's coming
dummy I knew you would come for me how
about we all just start shooting each
other time to endless
let's dig some Graves
you are not to be trusted are you in on
my Christmas list either
calvary's here cheers
we need weapons
and cars
cabin cars you like surprises I adore
them
I'd stay down if I was you you'll need
to hit me harder for that
the game's over down you lose
your last ride
then you might want to buckle up
thank you
foreign
[Music]